the town of soda springs idaho in the
usa lives up to its name because here in
geiser park in the center of town there
is a geyser that shoots soda water up
into the sky as in carbonated water
seltzer sparkling water whatever you
want to call it the stuff you'd find in
a bottle the geyser here isn't boiling
that's not steam underneath the town
there's a natural reservoir of
carbonated mineral water but while the
water is natural the geyser is man-made
and accidental 1937
a group of local businessmen started
talking about uh pool for soda springs
and
they started drilling they were about
out of money and about out of eight inch
pipe they were down 315 feet and they
quit for the evening they were having
dinner and they heard this loud
noise
they saw this column of water shooting
in the air and a crowd gathering the
businesses downtown were getting kind of
anxious because water was going
everywhere it was in the middle of
december and then they had to figure out
how to cap it it took them about two
weeks when they stopped drilling they
were right next to the water but they
were in a pocket of co2 gas and it
as they stopped they combined and that
formed the pressure that released it the
co2 gas also cooled the water to where
it was not hot enough for a swimming
pool turns out natural carbonated water
is a thing that happens in a few places
around the world where there's
underground water and carbon dioxide
held at pressure the geyser wasn't a
complete surprise i mean in the moment
it probably was but the town had already
been called soda springs for decades
because there were natural carbonated
springs near here that you could bathe
in the first english language accounts
date from the days of the oregon trail
which passed through this area although
the springs were used well before
european settlers ever got to the area
the pioneers would pick the warm springs
out to do laundry and they would
mix their flour to make their bread with
the soda springs because they didn't
need yeast and their bread would rise
and of the hundreds of springs that were
here when the early pioneers came
through
there are five that i know of left that
have soda water the majority of those
springs were covered up in
1923 when they built the alexander dam
the rest of them spring was in the way
it got filled in and covered over at one
time they bottled the water
not from any of the springs the city has
but they bottled it and sold it
worldwide so when this thing started it
wasn't so much a geyser as it was a
blown out well putting out enough water
to flood parts of the town with seltzer
the entire underground reservoir was
pushing up through the borehole the
geyser ran continuously for a while and
the officials at the park must have said
something about some irregularities in
old faithful and the secretary of the
interior sent a telegram to the city
offices telling them to shut the geyser
off immediately and notify them they had
done that so they did and then it was
determined that had no impact on the
geyser basin and so they give them back
the permission to operate the geyser
when i was a boy in
the 1960s
a city employee would go into a little
shed where
the control for the valve was
and manually turn the valve on and
manually turn it off if the wind was
blowing towards town he was not supposed
to turn it on now they have a electronic
timer and it goes off every hour on the
hour
someone realized that if they put a
timer valve on their new geyser well
that could be a pretty good tourist
attraction and the result is this
colossal 20 meter eruption for eight
minutes on the hour every hour all the
orange stuff around it is travertine
mineral deposits that have built up over
the years because this is mineral water
you don't want to park your car
where it might get overspray from the
geyser because of the mineral in the
water if you did that over time you'd
have a real problem getting that hard
water off some of the graves on the
northeast corner of the cemetery have
been impacted by the overspray as as the
walkway around it it's all coated in a
rock the headstone some of them are not
readable anymore the town's publicity
says that this is the world's only
captive geyser that does depend on how
you define it there's a couple places in
germany that would probably take issue
with that it does seem to be the only
one in america and as far as i can tell
it's the only one on a regular timer
where the public can just turn up and
watch for no admission fee i know the
obvious question is what does that water
taste like i could try and stand over
there with a glass for the next eruption
catch the water get soaked but i don't
need to because at octagon springs on
the other side of the railway tracks the
city has thoughtfully provided a little
ramp and you can just get a glass
that's really nice
i don't know what i was expecting that's
just nice lightly carbonated water it's
not too fizzy that's
i would happily buy that in a bottle
you